I HAVE EVERY CONFIDENCE, EVERY
CONFIDENCE IN YOUR WISDOM.
>> Laura: NOW THAT THE ORAL
ARGUMENTS ARE OVER, WHAT HAPPENS
NEXT?
ROBERT RAY IS A MEMBER OF
TRUMP’S LEGAL TEAM, HE JOINS US
NOW.
I’M SO TIRED OF COVERING THIS, I
GET TO PAT CIPOLLONE’S NAME
PRONUNCIATION WRONG.
>> I THINK WE ARE IN THE PROCESS
OF COUNTING VOTES TO SEE WHETHER
OR NOT THERE WILL BE WITNESSES
AND I WILL IMAGINE FOR MANY
SENATORS, HOW THE QUESTIONING
GOES AND THE ANSWERS THAT ARE
GIVEN MAY HAVE SOME BEARING,
IT’S OBVIOUSLY THEIR JUDGMENT TO
MAKE AND WE WILL KNOW THE ANSWER
PROBABLY AFTER A VERY LONG DAY
OF DEBATE RELATIVE TO THAT
QUESTION.
>> Laura: THERE WAS A LOT OF
JAWBONING ABOUT THE FACT THAT
PAT DECIDED TO YIELD BACK A LOT
OF HIS TIME, CNN AND MSNBC SAID
WE EXPECT HIM TO SPEAK FOR AN
HOUR AND A HALF OR TWO HOURS.
I THOUGHT IT WAS QUITE SMART --
WHAT ELSE ARE WE GOING TO SAY,
IT’S SO OBVIOUS, WE ARE GOING TO
GIVE YOU THE LUXURY OF TIME BACK
WHICH I THINK A LOT OF THESE
SENATORS PROBABLY REALLY LIKED.
>> I THINK THEY APPRECIATED IT.
WE ALSO DID WHAT WE PROMISED WE
WOULD DO AT THE OUTSET.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS YOU HAVE
RECOGNIZED FOR SOME TIME, WE
DON’T HAVE TRIALS AND ROVING
FACT GATHERERS TO DECIDE
EVERYTHING UNDER THE SUN, THE
TASK AT HAND IS TO HAVE A TRIAL
TO DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT IT’S
APPROPRIATE TO REMOVE THE
PRESIDENT FROM OFFICE -- PERIOD,
END OF STORY.
ONCE YOU’VE MADE YOUR ARGUMENT
WITH REGARD TO THAT QUESTION
WHICH IS AFTER ALL THE ONLY
QUESTION TO BE DECIDED, IT’S
TIME TO SIT DOWN AND LET THE
SENATORS -- AND PUT YOUR FAITH
AND TRUST IN THEM AS
PAT CIPOLLONE SAID OF THE END
AND RESPECT AND ABIDE BY THEIR
WISDOM, THEY ARE THE PEOPLE
SELECTED REPRESENTATIVES IN THIS
BODY AND THAT IS WHAT THEY ARE
ELECTED TO DO.
>> Laura: I THOUGHT IT WAS
REFRESHING THAT AFTER NADLER
BASICALLY ACCUSE THE SENATE OF
BEING COCONSPIRATORS WITH TRUMP
AND PAT CIPOLLONE COMES ALONG
AND SAYS WHY DON’T WE START TO
WORK TOGETHER?
WHY DON’T REPUBLICANS AND
DEMOCRATS START WORKING TOGETHER
FOR THE COMMON GOOD, DO THE
THINGS YOU WERE SENT HERE TO DO?
THAT WAS REALLY INSPIRING AND
PEOPLE WHO AREN’T POLITICAL
WATCH THAT AND ARE PROBABLY
SAYING TO THEMSELVES THAT SOUNDS
GOOD.
>> SURE IT DOES.
I WILL SAY IN CONNECTION WITH
YOUR PANEL, THIS VERY QUESTION
IS NOT IN A VACUUM.
DURING THE ANDREW JOHNSON
IMPEACHMENT SINCE IT WAS VERY
CLOSE TO THE END OF ANDREW
JOHNSON’S UNEXPIRED TERM THAT
OCCURRED AT THE RESULT OF THE
ASSASSINATION OF
PRESIDENT LINCOLN, WHY WOULD WE
WANT TO REMOVE THE PRESIDENT OF
OFFICE WHILE THERE’S AN ELECTION
COMING UP AND AS A RESULT OF
THAT ULYSSES GRANT WAS ELECTED